المشهد لم يختلف كثيرا عن الاحتجاجات التي
اندلعت اثر مقتل ماسه امين في ايران
فسيارات الاسعاف لم تعد تنقل جرح الاصابات
الداميه وانما فتيات يبكينا توعكا فجائيا
اصابهن او يعانين من ضعف العضلات والخمول
والغثيان لساعات او يعانين من حالات
اختناق وفي احدث موجه تسمم تعرضت طالبات
من سبع مدارس في مدينه اردبيل ومن ثلاث
مدارس اخرى في العاصمه الى تسمم اثرار نوع
من الرذاذ يتكون من غاز النيتروجين الذي
يستخدم في الصناعه او كسماد زراعي ونشرت
مقاطع عده لاحتجاجات اولياء الطالبات
المصابات وقالوا ان المدرسه تتصل بنا
وتطلب ان ناخذ بناتنا دون ان تعطينا
معلومات اخرى
وفي هذه الموجه الاخيره من مسلسل الارهاب
البيولوجي ينتظر الاهالي كلمه تفسر ما
الذي يجري حينما يرسلون في ذات اكبادهم
الى المدارس فتاره يقر مسؤولون في وزاره
الصحه بحدوث حالات تسمم لكنهم يصرون على
انها ليست بمواد كيميائيه بينما يؤكد
مسؤول اخر من ذات الجهه انه ليس فيروسا
لينتهي بالقول ان الاعداء وحدهم من يقفون
وراء كل تلك المصائب التي حلت على البلاد